un nouveau défi après avoir été
secrétaire d'état député et maire de
mantes-la-jolie l'une des plus grandes
villes du territoire pierre bédier se
lance à la conquête de la fédération les
républicains le président du conseil
départemental démarre sa campagne dans
un contexte compliqué pour son parti
recule au niveau national perte de 90 %
des adhérents en 2017 dans les yvelines
sa priorité pour inverser la tendance
retourner sur le terrain auprès des
militants retrouver une envie de militer
et de militer autour d'une génération
montante qu'on doit préparer pour les
futures élections et autour de
propositions claires aussi bien au plan
national qu'au plan local la dimension
programmatique ce travail là doit être
une de nos priorités
mais pas que il faut aussi faire de la
détection et puis de l'animation animer
des soirées débats créer une école des
cadres politiques pour faire de la
formation travaillait auprès des
militants et sympathisants quelques
ébauches de propositions que pierre
bédier a présenté devant près de 500
personnes au pec dans la salle ses
principaux soutiens qui met en avant son
expérience et son envie de rassembler un
certain nombre de jeunes qui ont
également fait le déplacement ont fait
pas du jeunisme et c'est important de
s'appuyer sur un socle d'expérience
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce dont a besoin
effectivement la droite c'est d'abord de
vraiment refaire le terrassement et puis
ensuite on construira tranquillement la
la maison et ça ça demande un petit peu
de temps c'est le seul aujourd'hui
puisse rassembler tous les militants qui
puisse demain également aider tous les
élus pour vous construire notre
fédération parce que c'est un homme qui
a une histoire
c'est un homme de terrain et c'est avant
tout un militant c'est tout dire de ceux
qui on peut compter
c'est un homme qui mouille sa chemise
pour les autres et c'est énorme qui
représenterait très bien les convictions
les à l'ère pierre bédier fera face
notamment au duo de candidats composé
par alexandra dublanchet othman deux
roues les élections à la présidence de
la fédération les républicains sont
programmées les 13 et 14 octobre
prochains